[音楽]
よろしくお願い致します今日はですね
クマムシと私というタイトルなんですけれども
マムシに金明
ああいう人ですね私のん
これまで日本にちょっとお話させていただきたいなと思います
クマムシのことをお伝えする前に
まず出会う前皆様や皆さんと同じぐらいの時ですねどういった噛んじゃったかって
ちょっとだけ入ります
お話させて頂きたいと思います父は高校時代なんですよ私はですね
神奈川の
私立学校に通ってたんですけれども
というときはですねまだ以前と気力ですね4
の木よく
6年間力で勉強勉強してないと
そして味をばいいですよね
ラン承諾のもあるんですよねはいん
でただ一酒の柱行ったのがスポーツを指定します
ストリートファイターii って言うんですけどあ
この若い人たちと未だに来ている方がいますね
各党にいい
今は
パソコンじゃないのかな
ファミコン
家のテレビゲームでありますけど当時はですねエイムセンターにしかなかったんです
これはですね毎日のように不調になって
これだけ唯一夢中になってまして
授業受けてもです猫はジョウビタキ黒板に行こうかってに行こう画面が勝ち上がってき
ている
キャラクターが動いにもっ
2ミールだけじゃの道超えておくん昇龍議員のでコスト高
授業中にん腕が勝手に来て学校を
やってるクライマー頭がおかしくなってました
[音楽]
そんな感じの6年間でしたので
動画来なかったですね高校3年生の最後ですが15点でしたねこれ何か中は全額を三巻
分合計だ中
じゃあ300拳銃集55点
高校3年生
でも311バン注300で一番という学年最下位
楽器たので当然ながら料理ですねで理論せいかダガーだいると言う
私立大ように彼よりました
ここでですねちょっと転機が訪れまして
この神奈川ないもの
セッティングにヒーロー戦
という方という
やりましたこの先生が面白かったんですねまずジェンダーこういう生物学の授業なん
ですけど
株のストックオプションの話とかですね
そういった話をし始めたいちょっと変わってるなぁ友達変わっている
ちょっと人が好きだったのでそこの研究して入ったらでこの先生が
マムシの辺境していたことがありました
この二まま7話は非常に強いんですけれども
初めて高み圧力にも伝えられるようという研究でねーじゃん論を出した
これが1なるほど億万しては面白いんだなと言う
を通した最初のきっかけでした
えクマムシなんですけど
非常に小さい生き物で後ろや前せていますよ今中ではありません
体長1ミリ以下でその辺のですね道路の後家の中とかに住んでいます
me
漢方動物のぎっ
動画をお願いします
今急なんですね水の中でだけで
活動できます
ところがですねまぁ b 水がなくなるとどんどん
脱水してです
金沢になります
このキャラからなるとピーターさん方をしてしまってい
どんどん体から水が降ってい
最終的には
孟母かなんです
かなかな状態でごまっ
美神で売ってるのかなぁと思うんですけれどもはたちの水をかけてやると
給水します値段がた方が膨らんできて足が講師
連合木はじめ
10分押しますとです何事もなかったかのように
いい機会
非常に不思議な生き物ん
そのさっきのカタールになったときです
乾燥して仮死状態には官民と呼ぶんですけども乾眠状態だと
制作思いましたよ症法案するありゃあ
調停いようと思います
宇宙のシンクの
今生えられま地上最強の生物と言われているわけですね
このクマ墓所ですね最初に見た時に思ったのですね
まず可愛い
そしてこう変形したりしてトランスフォームかっこいい強くてなるといい
でパターン
この大学での研究してるぐらいにしこんな面白い氷室のかなおそらく世代中の研究者が
研究していて
いながらこうクマムシを研究してもなかなか
新しく発見できないだろうと思ったんですねところがですね
ん
論文検索しているのですねあんまり
過去の研究ではないことがわかったんです
筋ジスれていないがこれは
もしかしたら自分でもなんかやったら新しい発見ができて
もしの研究で大臣者になるワンチャンスあるんじゃないのってるべきなんかこう
劣等生だったのにそんな妄想を抱いてですねこれやるしかないなと
音とわけですねはいその後ですね
クマムシ研究をはじめたんですけれどもダフィーてに始めたんですけどちょっと大きな
問題がありまし
というのは
異形の研究というのはですね実験して腰移行したから
フェアして安定的に研究するとがあるんですけども
クマムシをして玄関なかなかシーンができなかったんですね
そんな時です2003年ぐらいですねか
鈴木敦さんという慶應日吉の
キャンプ地に入る選手なんですけども
鈴木さんが後にクマムシのよ肉食のクマムシをはじめ
シークに成功しましたこれじゃあこの分足を使う
シェイプすることで研究がすると思ったんですね
この子の方に感謝の肉食でしては無視というまた微小貝ようなん
いっぱい食べるんですけどこれやってみた実践大変だ何が大変かというとですね
まず
横綱へ5人問4は
いっぱい食べるのでは虫雄また高飼育してレースになった
さらにですね
低い回以上ですね足にゴミガキかかるとひっくり返っちゃう
そうそこで地域で起き上がれなくてさを取れなくしてしまうなので細かいゴミをですね
顕微鏡で5を取ったりたいとミクロン対応
パターン
を起こしてあげたりとか口のところにも餌を持っていただけだ
やってましたけどこれすると1日中謙虚になる
どうかしなっちゃうんです
なんかこう親父者なども介護をしているん
思ってですね
歩いですねオニクマムシが溶けながらどんな顔に落ちてくる
開く聞いたりしてこれもダメだなと思っ
思って一からん
新しい区マンションの種類
体力矛盾流そうと思って出会ったナホに横綱となりまし
という種類です骨ほざくな虫は
緑色の装備クロレラですそれを食べてくれることがあります
お箸より簡単でしたうんっ
介護する人もなくフロロ本とあげればそれで放置して大丈夫
ということでよかったと思ってですねこれ
やっと
まあ
クマはその人気できるぞということでいろんな体勢とかとか静大のデータをとって
研究成果がいいバグで打ってたんですねそこでん浣腸これを
回し強いのでー
家を持っているような緊急で一人いいんじゃないかなと思ってですね皆さん
開催している宇宙生物科学会議です
学会があるんでそこで発表しました
マムシの研究とか待った犬っていうといないんだと今
ちょっとお門違いなんじゃないかなと思ったら
学生大会ビジョンの世代がピン3型の
拡張2番目の b
の称号をもらったんですね私も2とちっちゃいものがダニも表彰されるのが
が来ないとか表彰されることはなかったので
はじめにまとも3校お腹表彰されているサイマー
非常に候補緊張して足が降れば約束
後半なんですけども美味しかったですね自分の緊急が認められたんだなと思って紹介し
た
入ってそのまま勉強がですねあ
他の研究者にも広がっていって
割とですね大きな大きなというかで町田中国をいろんな
クマムシの研究者だ
よこさんの後ろを使うように
になっていいわゆる中ジャパンチームみたいな
で一つあったんですね食べて私も不満星の研究た稼ごうと
クマムシ激しくなった
なんですけどもところがですね
博士を取ってい
ということですねつぎに大体は博士研究林になるんですけど私の場合は
10カ所くらいにも来ないで処女活動したんですけど全くところも開かなかったんです
ね
でもキングちゃんやめようかなっても1年くらい経って全然どこにも就職できない何か
思ったんですけど
言いず
アリー40組雇うスペルのがあってそこがなかった
ね
nasa に入ってですねシリコンバレーの謎ネームズーム研究所家ですけどそこに
行きました
なんかこんな感じですね
nasa 者と分 p 有バスが最寄り駅から来てるんですね
でここで通ったりとか日高ペグ広くていいですね
こんなでっかい創造
あるんですけども
すごいなと思うんですけど中に入ってみると実験所意外と古い日本の大学の方は綺麗
だったりとか
香十段快適なやつを売ってるんですけど
そんな中ですね
小ずるいんですけどもまぁ面白かったらませ研究もそうなんですけども街と人
面白い人が多くてですねアメリカの高分化とかそういったものも学べだ
kk できたっていうのは非常に方現在車持っています
ここでもですねあの
宇宙生物学的な研究をしてですねふま牛の紫外線に対する
大勢の女か日の一端を
彼に改名してですね
も出しましたけど
この後にですねまたフランスに行ったりとか
行ったんですけどさだ
日本に帰ってきてもですねなかなかちょっと私の中で疑問があって
就職活動にたくさん失敗した経験からこうおーどうも研究職市に行くのにためらいが
あったんですね
何か良い組織に頼って自分の
就職口を探していかないといけないキュートに今もって何かご自分で尻で何が
砲金研究活動をできるされないんだなと
本当にいいで町道
当時ゆるキャラミんだんだん
なのであ客と言いま
クマムシ可愛いかなキャラクターにしたら絶対受ける関係者
いい思っ
でこの友紀アナでキャラクタービジネスそして
研究資金
緊急所の式中立てて案も全然少々生じゃないんですよ
今考えるさらに頭がおかしい発想なんですけども当時本日に思っていて火がついたら
クマムシさんというキャラクターですね自分で作ってです
調査課の
8畳表現と登録してやりましたはい
それに東京取っちゃってですねグッズもをするためですね
キーチェーンとかバッグとかち年度イングでっかいのを取得します
しまいにはですねぇー株式会社タイトーとですね
ライセンスキーを押しまして全国のゲームセンター予防ペチャの経費にもなりました
やっぱりいきいきだなとしかしまぁ私のゲームセーター
中毒症状なんストリートからジャズ中毒症状に入ってから足はなくにすごい時間かかっ
たんですけれども
銀様に取っていかないと思ったんだけどまさかこんな何十年もだって
ゲーム線がかかるなるん
もうこんな感じですねこれで
緊急たちよ友達なかなかですね実はそうはうまく以外ね
範囲
大手のキャラクターニーズねあのちょっと駆逐されてしまいまして
まあ
その
設けたかどうかいう豚とんであんまりその嘘当初の目論みのように
研究所目指すということはなかったんですけどもだからよくやってよかったなと思った
のは
ん
クマムシを知らなかった人たちがこのクマムシさんというキャラクターをきっかけに
本物の c 興味を持って
育てクマムシの知名度を広げたということに関してはすごく良かったなと思うむしろお
金よりもそちらは大丈夫かなぁという分かりました
それですねあとはこうクマムシのワークショップとかもですね
開催しましてこのようにですね
緊急が本職ではない人々
した小学生から上は
の社会人の方まで
ね色んな国まぶしの研究とかですね実験をしてもらって
こう以上にも受け取ったりとかですねそういうことをやらせます
あと磯から1弾はピョン種のアプリを作ったりとかですねする方も
いらっしゃったりとかしてこれは小学生なんですけどもこちら
もう
誰も
開発できなかったようなやり方で自分が見つけたクマムシの心境で紹介しないんじゃ
支部的な嬢とか
いろいろですねまぁまだまだな虫には
緊急余地があるということがですねまぁ思い知らされたということで面白いなと思うん
ですねはい
あとですね今年岩ですねクラウドファンディング
普通研究者というのは組とか財団とかに保険申請書を書いて研究費を獲得したりするん
ですけども
クラウドファンディングはですね
ネットで
不特定多数の方々から小学の方資金をいただいてい
研究資金集めをいただくと中でミスト不自由クラブマン人された
そこで行ったりとかですね結局ですね色んな方
何ですかねやり方があるわけですね
[音楽]
私が後最後に言いたいなんですね
ちょっとたく皆さんのイメージする研究者来て私と違うなと思うんですが
違うと思うんですけれどもやりが入ったっけのいろいろあっていいと思うんですよ
特に今の時代というのはもう何か好きなことがで何かやりたいと思ったらそれを極める
ためになりふり構わないで
[音楽]
みんなやってやり方じゃなくってまあこうやったらいいじゃないのでやり方で
その人でも気にせずにですね
をアピールしたりとかいろいろやり方だと思うんですけれども
何でもいいと思うのでできその
あまり好枠に必ず3
何かこうやりたいことがあればいろんなあり方で逡巡し資金
していったらいいんじゃないかなと思いますところで私の話を話せておきます
ありがとうございました
[拍手]